Alright guys, so this is going to be the final, I would say, example for the strategy.
So as you can see, we made high, high, high, low, high, low, low, low, sorry, high, high,
then we created lower, high, lower, low, lower, low, lower, low, then we created high, high,
high, low, high, high, high, and then after we swept the high of the Asian range, which
is this, during the lunch break, we swept the high, and then we had a market structure
shift, as you can see right around here, alright, and then if I mark out the autoblog, this
is the autoblog that we have, alright, so you would have entered here, you stop, should
have gone here, if it went there, you would have gotten stopped out, but if you had you
stopped here, you would have targeted the Asian session range, and this would have given
you a 3.26-risk reward rate.
So we will be moving on to our next strategy after this video, and as we guys in the next
trading strategy video.